[Music]
all right so today we're gonna try
something i've been wanting to do for
years a knife fight where we actually
dip the knives in red paint so that way
you can know when you get a hit on
somebody because when you're using
rubber knives and swords it's all
guesswork really is like how you hit
somebody where you hit them it's like oh
i vaguely remember getting hit over here
nick
what's up you need help outside
why were you shooting we're shooting a
paint fight
a pain fight yeah
dude i'm gonna ruin another pair of
clothes if we do that
no you won't every single time i ruin my
clothes when we shoot the paint and not
even using that much paint let's go just
the flight you only want the edge you
know
i'm just saying you don't want slappers
you know what i'm saying so that way
when you're slapped you'll be able to
see versus the slice you gotta you gotta
wet your nose welcome in peter you're
already listening already nick's lost
like five pairs of pants did he get red
on you yeah he's already died it's okay
the shirt was five dollars somebody with
a knife is incredibly hard to deal with
because you're going to get cut even if
you're a really good fighter and you
know how to handle it it's very hard to
survive a knife fight without getting
touched so we should put that to the
test you know what would make great
content for the corridor channel
this knife fight what yeah dude you're
crazy did you not see the poll that
people post i saw the poll but sometimes
people don't know what they want until
you give it to them you know what i'm
saying i know exactly what i want and
that's for you to get cut
there's no fantasy here this is real
life three two one fight
all right we got a slice here on the
back of the shoulder nico you got sliced
in the arm for sure i got hit in the oh
i am in the back next to each other just
hit each other almost in the same spot
jake got me first a cut like that you'd
survive and keep swinging so i would say
this fight is far from over guys second
round
it's about to begin butterfly
a butterfly a monarch butterfly piece
floating around here
oh boy all right fight
slice them right across the chest
oh that's a gnarly one jake won nipple
watson
i got knicks again you didn't cut my
nips oh that's a that's a solid slice
actually it's a solid slice oh we're
doing left hands now it's the final
round fight
dude my abs hurt so bad your ribs would
stop it from probably getting yeah you
would have just slashed my ribs
the internet's down again peter
you guys don't even know
this happens every six to eight weeks
the internet will just go down for a
half a day or an entire day it's
impossible to get anything done when
you're a company that makes videos for
the internet but we have to deliver this
cut to
to a brand for a brand integration that
we're doing in the in the next video and
we can't get it over to him so
christian's gonna have to take off go
somewhere that does have internet and
then
i'm trying to
get this production going for this other
thing we're doing yes i can look at
stuff on my phone but it's it's not
nearly the same thing trying to check
those 50 emails on your phone and
coordinate those with the rest of a
company
from a screen that's this big
light for you
we're going to change up the colors now
that we are moving into a new stage that
way we can differentiate the cuts we're
gonna go to bog green it'll show up
pretty well on the white keep it clean
gentlemen
oh you cut me in the arm wait i think
that's a i think there's a flick it felt
like a slap but instant replay pointed
my paint it looks like it might have
been a flick i may have gotten a nick
yeah
that's a slapper you got me with a
slapper
[Laughter]
well i think i got you i got you with
the trick
open you're like whoa and then i came
back and it's like
i gave you a lobster claw by
[Music]
three it it felt kind of like a slice it
looked like it was like a backhanded
slap oh you got it yeah that's a good
old slice those goldfish nick's my shirt
too all right you guys do that fight
left-handed here we go
so there's a new fighting style i'm
gonna introduce
yes the broken blade
i got you with like six up to six cuts
slice my my elbows hanging loose right
there
it's at the end i'm just slapping
so check this out you know how they're
the geotags on snapchat look at this one
look at this little geotag
look at that
it knows that's pretty cool wait for
it whoa that's crazy got our own geo tag
now did you guys just purchase a juicer
somehow what how did that happen i don't
know i just saw it
you just saw it somebody has to purchase
i just saw it did you do this nope how
big's a geotag what do you mean how big
is it like could you go do it can we go
into stressful zero we'll locate us this
corner didn't i don't know let's go see
yes
you're in corridor digital territory now
boys
it's on
scorpion strike
[Music]
a little arm cut
that's a smack right there
all right i guess you lost your right
hand round two round two fight
oh
i got you pretty clean there you could
give me a little bit of a slap but you
didn't make it out without getting
nicked semi-clean guys semi-queen
oh
skittish
this is to revenge my grandfather and my
son and my daughter
what
oh you just bumped me you didn't even
you want a gang you want to gang up yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
may the best fighter win
damage swan
[Laughter]
i want to paint your my name on your
tombstone
i could cut a lot
i got him with it with a good old
lineage strike dude yeah classic lineage
strike
sam's autopsy as you can see uh chest
hits were were a very popular uh way to
go with me i got this obviously the
lineage strike oh your left shoulder man
this was probably the most critical
strike it seems like yeah there's a
little here but this kind of looks like
oh there were that's a good strike oh
man yeah once again clean strikes that
was me i'm proud of that
so yeah once again the right arm you
want to put all your armor on the right
arm probably when you go on leave i have
one on my nose too yeah yeah i got
tyrion
the lineage strikes
clean slicing it's a really bad place to
get cut right yeah this is when i pitted
you yes
oh look at this look at the cleanliness
of this
and this one right here too clean
strikes what we've learned so far is
that once you commit and you know just
just run it through it you're gonna get
slashed either way so all you can really
do is make sure that your slash is a
better slash yeah
hey everybody last year we did something
really fun and that was the gift contest
where he asked people to make a gif gif
not jiff out of any of their favorite
scenes from a salmon eco video corridor
video it could really be anything as
long as it was corridor related today
marks the announcement of the second
annual gif contest pick up the best
givable moments and submit them for a
chance to win something really cool such
as a monopod some sweet limited edition
quarter digital merch or a fidget
spinner psych all the losers get fidget
spinners don't worry that's right so go
to any video you want make a gif however
you'd like stylize however you want and
send an email to us gifts corridor
digital.com submit your gift by
wednesday evening end of the day
wednesday evening details are in the
description below also in case you want
there's a little spider this little
spider hanging from the shotgun mic
where's red
but it was it's kind of a pitch for like
a feature film he's hoping someone will
like buy
and fund the movie so it kind of ends in
a bit of a cliffhanger but the premise
is amazing firebase
is
a film that takes place in 1970 vietnam
so during the vietnam war and there's
all this crazy stuff happening like
tanks are getting flown up into the sky
people are just exploding and like
really really brutal stuff and the way
they slowly reveal all of that is
actually
a direction i didn't anticipate it
started going like okay this alien or a
robot but then you're like wait what is
it
and then it ends and a cliffhanger is
like the guy's about to i won't spoil it
it's great
[Music]